stop being in love and start having fun
oh love's pretty fun summer just
give it a chance i hate to break it to
you but what people call love
it's just a chemical reaction that
compels animals to breed it hits hard
then it slowly fades
leaving you stranded in a failing
marriage break the cycle rise above
focus on science oh geez season five
rick is
way different than you season one rick
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that's back with a rick
ridiculous theory that if true will
expose
probably the best twist reveal any show
has ever conceived ever i'm not even
joking if this one is even remotely
close we're talking reveal on par with
game of thrones red wedding or them
needing to go back to the island on lost
now don't get me wrong i've loved the
start of season five of rick and morty
honestly it feels stronger than the
start of season four but even with the
episodes themselves being solid
something to me has felt off about it
all
the characters just i don't know it's
hard to explain but they're acting in
ways that don't quite fit with how
they're established to operate and i'm
not the only one to notice this
mixed in with all the preys have been
people calling out the fact that the
characters just seem out of sorts
there's also some outright mistakes
which we'll talk about here in a minute
that for any other creative team might
slide but for rick and morty just feels
sloppy in a way that the show isn't
something is clearly a miss
in season five and while it certainly
could be new writers or the break
between seasons or the fact that this is
the fastest turnaround time ever for a
season of the show
i'm not convinced that that's it i think
that there's a theory that explains
all of it the weird characters the
mistakes and the odd creative choices
that we've seen in these first few
episodes
i think that what we're witnessing in
season five is
evil morty's origin story things feel
off because we're following a
different morty and rick from a
different point of their lives and that
by the end of the season there's gonna
be a big rug pull moment when morty puts
on his signature eye patch
showing that he is in fact not the morty
we assumed he was a special shout out to
ghast writer on the game theorist
subreddit for bringing this idea to my
attention
it's an idea that seems outlandish at
first but the more that we thought about
it and re-watch the episodes the more it
starts to make sense well episodes 1 and
2 were relatively unremarkable it was
season 5 episode 3 that really got my
theorist senses tingling a rick
convenient mort in the episode morty
dates a copyright neutral version of
captain planet while rick and summer go
party on three different worlds in their
final moments before destruction and
while it's a fine episode to be sure
there's just tons of little things about
it that again
feel off first and foremost is rick we
watch as rick in the episode falls in
love with an alien okay grandpa the
meteor's almost here we can go now
ah now we still got time then stop being
in love and start having fun
oh love's pretty fun summer just give it
a chance this is totally out of
character considering that back in
season one
he was the one telling his grandkids
what people call love
is just a chemical reaction that compels
animals to breed focus on science
falling in lust yeah that's a total rick
move but wanting to make an emotional
connection with someone and then being
furious when the relationship ends yeah
that
that's not our rick and rick isn't the
only one breaking character here
we've also got morty falling in love
with planeteena honestly who could blame
him for falling in love with the
character voiced by allison brie but
throughout his entire emotional arc the
way he deals with infatuation
lust love and falling out of love feels
immature compared to where we saw morty
last season
in case you forgot back in the season 4
episode vat of acid the show's creators
loki slid an amazing 4-minute silent
film right into the middle of the
episode it covers the epic highs and
lows of a relationship where morty
learns to fall in love and deal with
loss and devastation and triumph and
heartbreak and reconciliation
and everything in between by the end of
the episode his maturity level has
skyrocketed
you know it was fun rick living without
consequences is great but then i started
wondering
what am i living for we are who we are
because of consequences
compare that to the level of emotional
development and maturity he displays at
the start of this episode
i don't want to think i want to see a
girl i like
slamming the door repeatedly in his
parents face no fewer than was that four
times
geez morty why don't you tell mom and
dad how you really feel morty's behaving
just like a petulant fourteen-year-old
my son is 14 miss i'm sorry morty
you're way too young wait morty can't be
can he that brings us to an even greater
inconsistency in this episode something
that goes beyond characters behaving out
of character because despite what his
mother might claim about his age it
doesn't make sense for morty to be 14 in
the scene based on what we've seen so
far i mean he was a 14 year old high
school student way back
in season one and assuming everything
that we've seen so far has been in
chronological order he should have
aged during that time at the start of
season five we had this exchange when do
i ask you for anything
when do you i haven't been to a full
week of school in years unless you think
that this is just morty exaggerating we
know that more than a year has passed
between season one and five based on the
fact that we had christmas episodes both
in the season one episode anatomy park
and in the season four episode
rattlestar rick galactica
at the very least a full year of time
has had to have passed between those two
episodes
making him more than a year older than
when we first started
so if the series is set in chronological
order it would make no
sense for morty to be a 14 year old high
school student at the start of season 1
and still be 14 years old in season 5.
some people might look at these sorts of
inconsistencies as the result of a
rookie mistake by the show's new writing
staff case you weren't aware over half a
dozen writers or staff writers on the
show got their first writing credit
starting in season four or later
but i'm not buying it i mean it's not as
though the writers kicked the show's old
staff off to make room for themselves
dan harmon is still the man at the helm
steering the ship come to think of it
the entire premise of that episode with
mr nimbus seems off too
it begins when their ship touches the
ocean violating an old treaty that
supposedly existed between rick and his
old nemesis mr nimbus but in the season
three episode rick lantis mix up rick
and morty had an entire off-screen
adventure
in atlantis all right morty you ready
for our adventure to the lost city of
atlantis
ready as i'll ever be rick it would have
been pretty hard to do that without ever
coming into contact with the ocean
especially considering that mr nimbus
himself
is from atlantis if you seek war with
atlantis you shall have it
something weird is going on with the
continuity of season five for as chaotic
and random as the show can seem at times
the reality is that rick and morty has
been far too intentional and deliberate
with its creative choices for all of
these inconsistencies to just be random
oopsies
last year at the adult swim festival's
rick and morty panel dan harmon and
several other members of the show's
staff and cast
briefly hinted at their plans for season
five dan
do you have any update that you can give
us about season five i know this is the
season four look back panel
there's pretty groovy things coming
regarding bath space beth was not a
one-on-one off character and indeed we
see space beth return in season five
episode two
after that dan harmon hands the baton to
executive producer scott martyr
there's epic cannon in season five
coming okay i mean fans are gonna like
get
knocked over by the can and we're about
to hit them with season five again this
is an
indication that the show's canon in
continuity is gonna be a big part of
season five meaning that what looks like
chronological inconsistencies
might be no mere accident in fact the
show seems to be outright drawing
attention to the weirdness of the
chronology i mean why
else would summer put on some giant 2010
throwback glasses in season five episode
three don't get me wrong i'm not saying
it's 2010 in the show that wouldn't make
sense but what i am
saying is that the show's creative team
are directing our attention to
chronology
in that same episode we see planetino
wearing a shirt that says vote no to
prop
6. since this also took place right
after she put out a huge forest fire
something that california is known for
i'm going to assume the no on prop 6
shirt was a reference to the california
ballot proposition trying to repeal a
fuel tax
that would make sense for the
eco-conscious planetina but the what
isn't important here it's the win
prop 6 was a big deal back in 2018.
yet another example to the show dating
itself for some strange reason though
come to think of it that's another place
where we potentially have a mismatch
between established rick and morty
cannon and what we see in season five
all signs point to the scene happening
in california but apparently it's only
200 miles from where the smith family
home is
there's a huge forest fire like 200
miles from me and in case you've
forgotten according to series creator
justin roiland the smith family lives in
washington state near seattle which is
far more than 200 miles away from the
border of california based on that
the most sensible explanation for these
chronological and geographical
mismatches is
what we're seeing in season 5 doesn't
directly follow the events of previous
seasons because this
isn't r rick and morty and by that i
mean the rick and morty from dimension
c137 the rickest rick and the mortiest
morty as you might call them from the
rickest rick there is
it would go without saying that the
rickest rick
would have the mortiest morty that said
despite them being from c137 they've
actually been living
in dimension c132 ever since the episode
rick potion number nine just wanted to
call that one out anyway to recap the
rick and morty that we're seeing in
season five so far
doesn't seem like our rick and morty
that we've spent the last four seasons
getting to know
in terms of both characterization and
continuity which leads me to believe
that this might be telling a story about
a completely different
family and i don't think that's a big
logical leap in fact i think that the
show is actively leading us in this
direction
season five episode two morty plicity
was basically an entire episode with the
premise what if we had an episode where
we focused on a version of the smith
family that wasn't
our version of the smith family in that
episode we get a repeated series of fake
outs where a smith family is presented
to us as the real smith family before
getting bumped off cause they were just
a bunch of decoys
the point of the episode was that we as
the audience are blind to who we're
really watching in any given episode and
that we're totally willing to get
emotionally invested in the characters
even though we're not watching our
canonical main version of the characters
that was insane i love you guys i've
totally changed that episode set up the
idea that we could be watching any
version of rick and morty at any point
that we turn on an episode so
why not the big reveal that the morty
we've been watching since the start of
the season
is in fact evil morty if they can do
that sort of fake out with multiple new
families within a single episode why not
do it with a single new family across
multiple episodes one thing i've talked
about a lot recently with these theories
is the show trying to strike a balance
between serialization
and episodic structures so how do you
balance the two what we learned is to
split the diff from now on rick and
morty doing a little of this
and a little of that yeah sometimes
we'll do classic stuff you know other
times we'll do whatever i think that
this could be part of a brilliant way to
as morty says
split the diff you get those classic
season 1 vibes by resetting the
characters back to an earlier part of
their emotional journey but it also all
pays off in the end fulfilling all those
promises about epic canon that will how
did he put it again
fans are gonna like get knocked over by
the canon we're about to hit them with
season five the immature version of
morty that we see in rick convenient
mort might seem like a continuity
problem or
our show's protagonist breaking
character but it might also just be a
setup to reveal that this is all part of
an emotional arc for a different morty
an evil morty and i don't think it's a
stretch to assume that this new morty
that we're observing in season five is
gonna turn out to be evil morty
let's consider what this version of
morty has gone through in the season
already in episode one he finally
manages to get a date with jessica and
then loses her and
not just in a they're not dating kind of
way anymore but for all intents and
purposes the jessica that he knew has
effectively
died i'm a time god then in rick
convenient mort we see him running
headfirst into a whirlwind romance with
planeteena maybe it's him trying to
bounce back after what happened to
jessica maybe it's just him with teenage
hormones but he experiences love
lust heartbreak and loss in very quick
succession going from saving wildlife in
the forest with your earth-loving
girlfriend to killing a bunch of
middle-aged has-beens to freer to
watching her murder
a bunch of coal miners that is gonna be
doing a lot of weird stuff to a young
teenage boy's emotional development
this is freaking you out huh it is a lot
to take in
this could be the start of an arc that
involves this version of morty being
pushed to an emotional breaking point by
the end of the season
luckily mom is there at the end of the
episode to comfort him mommy's here but
this is also the most that we've ever
seen morty relying on a family member
for emotional support what's gonna
happen if he loses beth or beth lets him
down
his one remaining emotional lifeline who
won't you know is
also back to drinking i'll get the wine
thank you something that we haven't seen
in a
very long time throughout season five
we've seen a weaker more vulnerable and
less capable version of rick accompanied
by a morty who's learning more and more
that it's up to him to take control of
things
at the same time that this same morty
seems to be getting pushed closer and
closer to an emotional breaking point
could this be foreshadowing a conversion
to the dark side after all remember that
by the time we met evil morty in season
1 he had already replaced his own rick
with a robotic puppet well we'll have to
wait and see but the more i re-watch
these season 5 episodes and the seasons
that led up to him the more i'm
convinced that this version of rick and
morty
isn't what it first appears i know that
i'm ready to go nuts when morty finally
reveals that evil eye patch but until
then
it's all just a theory all film theory
and subscribe to this channel so you can
be the first to tell all your friends
and co-workers these awesome theories
about all your favorite shows
or subscribe to the channel so you can
come back to this video and make fun of
me when i completely am wrong at the end
of the season
either way subscribing seems like the
right choice i'll see you all
next week